you're from virginia right
i can tell you're special
we are the future since you've become a
new multi-hyphenate
adding producer and studio head to
everything you already had
has that changed uh the projects that
you've picked and if that was maybe one
of your reasons for picking this one
i think when i read this project uh as a
human i connected to it i
felt like this film is the most timely
film
that we have for this year when you talk
about police brutality when you talk
about
the emotional labor that that black
women
have to do every single day and the
burden that we carry on our backs
to dismantle white supremacy to
dismantle systemic racism we're talking
about centuries of years
of work that we have been doing um
you can't talk about it without looking
at the past you can't talk about police
without realizing that in the south
during the civil
war uh the the policing
uh started uh as slave patrol
you know it was rooted inherently racist
policies
you know what i'm saying to harass to um
kill to destroy black people just for
existing just for trying to be free
and when we scream and defund the police
and abolish the police
that's because we know that that system
was built
on racist policy and it absolutely has
to go
so that made me pick the project because
there is a lot at stake when people
think things can't get worse
they absolutely will and they can uh
what we do
and what we don't do will determine our
future and i hope that white folks
watch this film and i hope that they
have some more accountability
if you're doing the work cool if you are
standing up and if you are fighting for
the dismantling racist policies that
continue to kill us that continue to
oppress us
then great if you're not you have some
work to do it's not up to black women to
do it
going forward as far as what you're
looking to do next with your next
chapters what type of roles are you
trying to see more often that maybe you
haven't seen before
i love the idea of of telling radical
and rebellious stories you know that
center around women
center around black women centered
around you know
my brothers and sisters and and folks in
the lgbtqia plus communities
um i i'm i'm all for that representation
on screen um you know our art for
artful films as well um
we've been reading a lot of scripts
we've been in in in constant
conversations with a lot of
amazing up and coming writers and and
and
novelists um so time will tell and i'll
know it
i'll know i'll know it when i feel it
[Music]
i'm coming
[Applause]
and i guess the biggest question is talk
about casting janelle
and how she came onto the project you
know we weren't sure
about who our veronica eden was going to
be we were
big fans of janelle as a musician but we
never considered such a big pop star
as the lead in our movie because we
didn't want
the persona of the person to supersede
that of the character in the movie
but when we saw janelle sitting in the
audience
of the grammys and she was looking
stoically at the stage
and it appeared that she was
trying to keep this bright
burning furnace deep within her from
reaching the surface but it was too
bright and
that for us uh
revealed that she was the veronica eden
that we had been looking for
we were blown away by how passionate and
enthusiastic she was
for the part she felt like this was
something that that she
needed to do and uh and
you know her and her team the the
passion kind of matched ours and
so we knew it was a it was a fit it was
a good fit with this film you guys have
been a little cryptic with the marketing
so i feel folks don't necessarily know
but the one thing they can tell is it
really blends
a lot of horror and thriller elements
like you can definitely
um take that from the trailer and so i'm
curious with you guys were there any
particular films that you drew
inspiration from again
not to tell folks too much on the plot
but maybe something they can look to for
what to expect
well you know we were really exhausted
as filmmakers by
recycled ideas and movies
of sequels and continuations of the same
story
so i think that we tried to create
something wholly original
and had our own way of doing it and
approaching it which
for people that might um
be attracted to something that's sort of
tried and true
that's not the expectation that they
should have of antebellum
antebellum is a reimagining um a
different way of telling this story
i will say that gone with the wind was a
huge inspiration in that we thought that
that movie was a horror film
um and that uh so much in fact that we
we were obsessed with obtaining the
lenses from that movie
and we got them and we shot um
antebellum with the lenses from gone
with the wind
we used the same weaponry that was used
to misinform to correct the record
and for that we are we are really uh
grateful that we were able to get them
what are we doing
what is the plan
i don't want to tell folks too much
about it other than to say it's a
brilliant horror thriller
so i'm just curious if maybe you guys
besides this one have
your own favorite horror thrillers
because i think this movie really
marries those two
kind of beautifully to be honest i
didn't really grow up watching scary
movies because
i'm a little [ __ ] i was scared i still
am
like i can't even really watch things
that are like
you know not horror that are just scary
thoughts about i don't know
like kidnapping i'm like someone's gonna
break in and kidnap me so i think
for me uh if we're talking just in the
trilogy because that's what i like to
say like this is the third installment
of you know you love that don't you
i do i do so out of the the out of the
two i mean obviously andrew bell and
what
but from the two i i'll have to go with
get out
um in regards to just you know how that
made me feel
i was it was fresh it was new it was
different so
i think usually the first time you see
something that's unique in its own sense
you know has a lasting impression so
that's what get out did for me
but i'm just like chrissy i'm not much
of a horrif
person because i think the the one movie
that spooked me to
not seeing anything after that was the
blair witch project
oh my gosh and then i was like
i still have not seen the original
exorcist for that exact reason
i'm a person that's literally paid to
watch movies
[Laughter]
no it is terrifying yeah
the reason why this one really hits so
hard is because of what all you guys did
on screen but especially janelle because
she really put this movie on her back
in a lot of ways both with the
antebellum stuff and the modern day
stuff so i'm curious
what was it like for you guys working
with her i mean i think she's a
brilliant
leader and i can't imagine
i i felt so much love and support on
set when we were you know in our scenes
from everyone from our directors to our
background artists everyone was so
supportive and i can't imagine you know
having
anyone else kind of in the front leading
us you know in the
in the direction that we were going
aside from janelle and chris and gerard
it was a great a great team
it was just magical uh you know i say
the first time i read the script when my
team was like oh
by the way uh janelle was playing the
league
that for me was just like the selling
point you know because she's a she's an
icon living
you know in my opinion you know
we call them renaissance man but she's a
renaissance lady
you know uh and so yeah just to be in
her presence man and just to see her
work
ethic uh was really you know inspiring
so i'm very very excited like you said
to see what you know what she's
capable of doing because we just started
to see
uh who janelle rooney really is when it
comes to her her range so
very very exciting you
you're not like the others
[Applause]
the one thing i will say is especially
with y'all's characters not the lightest
of subject matters so
it's not always something fun uh but how
did you guys keep it light on set i
imagine that you guys found a way to
maybe sort of move past that to still
have a really jovial atmosphere
sometimes i don't think that it's
necessary to have the lightness on set i
mean i
i it's necessary for when
you have when you're working for like
six months on something but this was
such a short amount of time
you know we really only had six to eight
weeks of trying to get
you know everything done that i feel
like you have to kind of honor
the energy that's taking place you know
and i feel like there was less need to
sort of
pick it up set it down pick it up second
set it down um
i think the real catharsis of humor and
just letting joy back in
was when we were able to meet offset um
directors uh and they're really adamant
about having cast dinners
bringing us all together so that we can
kind of just like live
in a little bit of like finding our joy
finding our humor
finding who who we were together um
because we were about to become
pretty uh you know intense characters
towards each other on set
and um i i really valued how they
protected that energy
so that you know if we did need to carry
it because that's a hard energy to set
down
you really do have to kind of it's it's
like there's a marathon
and you just have to keep at it you know
it was very day-to-day
it depended on the day it depended on
the scene it depended on who you were
working opposite
um one thing we all had in abundance was
a beautiful sense of safety and love
and like understanding that we were all
on course for a common goal which we
understood the gravitas of a movie like
this
of a script like this first and you know
what it did to each one of us viscerally
um and um yeah sometimes i mean you know
it's really interesting me and tom guy
the moment we saw each other we were
laughing joking we went so
deep quick because we understood that
you know our characters had
um a history jasper and eli
in the film just their
how they're so reactive off each other
um that i
i was really um you know i was so you
know
when we did come to doing very sort of
powerful
disturbing scenes
i i couldn't have asked for someone a a
better sort of scene partner and
obviously janelle as well there are
certain moments of
qc and you know it was um it was it was
an amazing sense of um
of safety and and uh you know
history and that we wanted to do it
justice and um obviously me and jenna
you know we were playing these
characters but we had a great dialogue
and we wanted to
create and conform and construct these
people
you know we understood the the
responsibility if that makes sense i
wanted to ask you guys about working
with janelle because i know
in addition to everything else i mean
she really puts this movie on her back
and i feel like
it's such an incredible performance so
if you could both uh talk real quickly
and i'll start with you jack about
working with her
um she was wonderful she was it was it
was
from from day one uh we sort of sat
around
just the actors in a little circle and
she said um
nothing's off the table this is a safe
place you know
uh go there i want you to go there we
need you to go there this is important
and from that they on um
we felt so you know it's very lucky and
and she does she gives a tour to four
she
she was you know the spirit the person
who drove this movie i'm
with her from the beginning and you know
pumping my fist in the air at the end
um you know she's you know the true
embodiment of a superhero
of what a superhero should be you know
not mythical and all the rest of it
she's true
yeah and even beyond that i mean i feel
like something i witnessed that i'd
never seen
uh coming from a female actress leading
a film before is just the amount of
self-advocacy
that she sort of demanded not only of
herself but of others like she really
was
she knew her process well enough to
respect it to communicate it
to you know um sort of you know respect
and then
it also invited other people's
self-advocacy
of like oh great now we're like in a
like a respectful space
like she i just think that she led this
language of consent and respect that
really
um you know all the other actors on set
benefited from and i just felt like it
was just like such beautiful leadership
[Music]
i'm just curious if either of you have a
favorite horror thriller
um besides antebellum and gabby i'll
start with you
parasite i'm reminded because i see it
behind you but parasite
is with me right now parasites sitting
on my lap i cannot think of anything
scared like when the woman was coming up
the stairs in the home and she's cooking
the
i freaked out watching
parasite it is the greatest film i've
seen in years years years
and it's horrifying yeah yeah
i agree and hilarious too which is a
strange thing
i love the way they talk to each other
they'd be like like i love
that it felt like oh look at us holding
hands i was just saying this but i
i the first horror film that i ever saw
and the one that will always stick with
me the hardest maybe because it was my
first
was alien just the deep space
the aesthetic the feeling of it the
alien
everything about it like it just i
remember not being able to eat anything
that looked like it could be like
guts for like a year after that i was
like
i'm eating pop-tarts only the inside
looks too much like this
this film and you ladies are incredible
in it but in a lot of ways
obviously it very much rests on the
shoulders of janelle monae and she's
absolutely incredible in it and so i'm
just curious
as to if you guys have what it was like
working with her what was like for y'all
janelle is she's so sweet and so giving
and warm
uh such a gracious woman and
has such integrity i mean she carries
herself in such a beautiful way
it's just a she's like a beautiful human
being
um when we worked together she had just
come off of five weeks of
you know filming all of the most dark
things that a human being could possibly
have to put themselves through
and despite that she was still so warm
and open
and uh and i'm so grateful to her for
everything that she gave this project
because
it's so powerful because of how much she
put herself through
yeah she's like a warrior statue
absolutely
like she is every bit that she is in the
last
10 minutes of the film alone that's who
she is on set that's who she is as a
person
um and yeah after five weeks of all the
um
slave [ __ ] she she was very excited
to have lily and i and restaurant scenes
and hotel scenes
i think it was like it was a nice
reprieve for her
and for us no i mean it's
it's actually it's good that you mention
that too because that's actually my next
question which is
how did you guys sort of keep it light
during all of this
because i know this is not always the
easiest subject matter if you will
it's true and yet gabby and i arrived
and we hadn't had to experience any of
the other things i mean we both read the
script of course
we were aware in what context our scenes
were landing
but we arrived and it was fun it was
full of i think at that point the cast
and crew were all ready to have some fun
and um gabby is a powerhouse comedian
she is the most empathetic just
whip smart has the like pee in your
pants comedian
and we just had so much fun it was a
blast i mean
it was a dream to play with her we did
have a lot of fun to be fair new orleans
is uh dope and they have drive-through
dockery stores so well
it's very hard to not be super fun
there okay wrinkle tonight
what is your emergency
foreign